cinco días después de los actos
multitudinarios convocados por el
presidente jair bolsonaro contra la
corte suprema una parte de la oposición
baja las calles el río de janeiro y en
las principales ciudades de brasil para
pedir el impeachment del mandatario
brasileño
los movimientos brasil libre y demoraría
que se hicieron famosos en 2013 durante
las protestas contra el aumento del
precio del autobús fundó el mundo con la
manifestación que como vemos es pequeña
porque los dos principales partidos de
la izquierda no se han querido sumar que
especialmente el partido de los
trabajadores del ex presidente luis
inácio lula da silva que prefieren
convocar sus propios actos en octubre -
por lo tanto que la oposición está
dividida y mientras tanto a más de 130
peticiones de impeachment en el
parlamento y el presidente de la cámara
ardor de irak humanos con invocación
porque es un aliado de bolsonaro por su
lado que está cada vez más preocupado
porque ve su reelección cada vez más
lejos y además está perdiendo
popularidad primero por la gestión de la
pandemia y la crisis económica y ahora
después de dar marcha atrás y de pedir
disculpas decir que nunca quiso ofender
a los poderes y adoptar un tono de
conciliatorio que ha desagradado a sus
bases más radicalizadas se espera que
las próximas semanas habrá cada vez más
protestas como éstas de varios partidos
pero la stampa es de una oposición cada
vez más dividida